here are the 10 life-changing micro
habits you can adapt quickly to improve
your emotions and productivity part one
habit number one is park the car a
thousand yards away from your home or
office so that you get some activity in
every day and you're not just sitting at
your desk habit number two is follow the
one minute rule the idea here is any
tasks you can do in under one minute do
it right away instead of delaying these
include things like recycling junk mail
hanging up your coat responding to a
text closing the drawer screwing the lid
on your jar of peanut butter habit
number three is make your bed before you
get your morning coffee the idea here is
to get a little bit of sense of
accomplishment and pride so that you can
have a more productive day because you
had a productive morning habit number
four is count to ten before you reply to
out of the blue questions and they're
here is we hate being interrupted and
when you're interrupted you don't show
up as your best self so instead of
responding immediately and saying
something you might regret count to ten
before you reply and habit number five
is review your goals at least once per
day if you don't know why you're doing
it you will not be productive